si un médico está preocupado de que un
paciente tenga diabetes o que esté en
riesgo de contraer diabetes sugiere
realizar una prueba que se llama a1c lo
que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
empezar desde que significa a1c y cómo
está esto relacionado con la diabetes es
decir con los efectos de la diabetes que
sería tener una concentración alta de
azúcar o hiperglucemia así que voy a
dibujar aquí un glóbulo rojo bueno te
preguntarás qué tienen que ver los
glóbulos rojos pero para allá vamos los
glóbulos rojos podríamos decir que más o
menos se ve como esto y son los
portadores en mayores de oxígeno en
nuestra sangre y dentro de los glóbulos
rojos podemos encontrar esta proteína
que es la hemoglobina y hay millones de
estas
la hemoglobina también es lo que hace
que la sangre sea roja cuando se une con
el oxígeno que produce este color
y vamos a escribirle aquí hemoglobina
y resulta que si primero voy a dibujar
esta versión grande de la hemoglobina
hay glucosa cercana a la hemoglobina
como lo estoy dibujando aquí y en este
escenario que tenemos aquí donde hay
mucha glucosa es el canal hemoglobina
existe la posibilidad no es alta pero es
una posibilidad de que la hemoglobina y
la glucosa se unan y en este caso que
tenemos hemoglobina a la que se le
adhiere glucosa obtenemos algo que se
conoce como hemoglobina glicosilada
hemoglobina glicosilada bueno y como
estado usando verde para la glucosa aquí
lo escribí en verde también y otro
nombre para la hemoglobina glicosilada o
la hemoglobina que tiene adherida
glucosa es hemoglobina a1c
hemoglobina a1c y ahora me imagino que
las cosas empiezan a ser sentido en tu
mente o sea que una prueba de a1c es
medir de tu hemoglobina el porcentaje
que es hemoglobina glicosilada esto es
del total de la hemoglobina y poder
medir cuál es el porcentaje de la
hemoglobina a1c los valores normales
para este porcentaje de hemoglobina a1c
si los valores normales están en el
rango del 4 al 6 por ciento bueno es
importante hacer notar que en diferentes
personas puede haber diferentes
concentraciones o porcentajes de
hemoglobina a1c pero estos son los
rangos que consideramos normales vamos a
poner aquí que este rango es del 4 al 6
por ciento es normal y aquí vamos a
decir ahora que si tu nivel es mayor que
el del 7 o el 8% eso consideramos
o sea si tienes 9 % pues es alto y esto
pues es una medición de la cantidad de
glucosa que hay en nuestra sangre porque
a medida que haya mayor glucosa en
nuestra sangre crecerá la probabilidad
de que se una a la hemoglobina es decir
tendrás un porcentaje mayor de
hemoglobina a1c y lo importante de todo
esto es tener una idea de la cantidad de
glucosa en nuestra sangre si recuerdas
hemos estado hablando hasta ahorita de
este asunto de la diabetes y hemos
reconocido que la cantidad de azúcar en
la sangre pues es variable variable en
el transcurso del día depende de qué
tanta actividad que tienes en el día
depende también de cuánta consumiste si
una cosa es hacer muestras e ir tomando
muestras y los niveles de la hemoglobina
a1c más bien se refieren a la presencia
de los últimos meses de glucosa en tu
sangre
sí porque estás hemoglobinas este tienen
una vida estimada de 120 días y 120 días
bueno seamos cuidadosos no quiere decir
que el sac sea exacto o sea que nace un
día y a los 120 días ella no está
podríamos pensar que algunos tienen
apenas unos segundos de vida y otros
pues se pueden acercar a los 120 días y
si pensamos que el promedio podría ser
de 2 meses entonces cuando hacemos la
medición
estamos encontrando resultados para los
últimos dos meses entonces una medición
como ésta del 78 por ciento me puede
indicar que en los últimos meses que
tengo una concentración mayor en mi
sangre que sea glicol izado la
hemoglobina y mi nivel es mayor que la
persona normal y eso me está indicando
que el nivel de azúcar en mi sangre es
mayor y arriba del 4 al 6 por ciento de
mi hemoglobina está siendo glicol y zara
y bueno esto podría entonces explicarnos
qué es
a 1 quiero mencionar aquí en el vídeo y
yo no soy un doctor que estas mediciones
de la 1 se existe una discusión de qué
tan efectivas son d en realidad que
están viviendo y que tanto reflejan esta
presencia de azúcar en el tiempo y como
lo mencionamos puede haber dos personas
con la misma concentración de azúcar en
su sangre y tener niveles distintos de
a1c y se puede deber a su edad oa otras
condiciones médicas